[Musique]
chaque année des millions de jouets sont
créés est parfaitement conçu pour
apporter du bonheur aux enfants du monde
entier
mais qu'arrive-t-il aux jouets qui ne
sont pas parfaits
la ville est mis aujourd'hui les noms
des fonds nous rendent unique
ça vaut la peine qu'on se batte pour toi
puisque tu pourras vrai manque de
petites bandes de poupées moche à la
moindre chance ici tout le monde est
prêt
avenue à l'institut de la perfection où
seuls les meilleurs se tiendront le
souhait de l'enfant
[Musique]
je n'ai pas longtemps les amis
courtois c'est quoi ton adéquat j'adore
les noms les terreaux tu joues pas
d'accord ce charabia
wente assure